microphone on right hello everyone good
evening everyone
7:30 we'll get started we've got no
visitors here everyone is aware of the
evacuation procedure and just a reminder
that the meeting is being audio recorded
right I've got apologies for absence
I've got cancer Steptoe has been
substituted by Councillor cut more
councillor Wilson who's been kept
substituted by councillor mr. high
councilor Milne who's been substituted
by councillors very anyone else okay
thank you okay lovely that takes us very
quickly through vital for already
minutes of the meeting held on the 16th
of March 2017 you happy for me to sign
those as a correct and accurate record
okay just do that for first bit of
administration but this is the first
member meeting since the events in
Manchester and I wonder if it is
appropriate if we just take a minute to
reflect and remember those that lost
their lives and those that were affected
on Monday so if you wouldn't mind
take a minute please okay
thank you
obviously we've got just the one item on
the agenda tonight with regard to item
five declarations of interest so just
got one statement or bit of advice
please yes that's right the application
this evening relates to land where
rockford district council is actually
the landowner as a result of which all
members here tonight have a
non-pecuniary interest and therefore
under the Constitution I would be
inviting you to declare a non-pecuniary
interest however about the course
doesn't prevent you from participating
this evening do any members take issue
with that
if the minutes could reflect everybody's
non-pecuniary in first place there any
other pecuniary interests okay thank you
so I to MEK
which is 65 Rockford Avenue Raley
constructing a new vehicle a new surface
to form a driveway 265 mr. strengths is
visitation through this one Thank You
them and this application you'll see
members from the report is for a vehicle
er access serving the property at the
farthest end of Brock bad when you shown
who the follow the cursor edged in red
as members be familiar with it's part of
a wider green area that links between
Brock's furred and cockpit Avenue at the
top here we have the Rayleigh Lodge
public house these dwellings here about
1950 s in age and comprising mostly
bungalows most of which have got
drive-ins along the side but the one at
the very end here is landlocked the
turning head as you'll see at this edge
of the the turning head of the street a
time gives a footpath that it doesn't
give a vehicle er access to this site
now the owners I understand have
approached the council as the council
owns the land and that's why it's
brought before you tonight
to see if access was possible and I
understand the license has been granted
but obviously being outside of the site
it does need planning permission as well
so if we can just see the details of the
application this is what the applicant
has put together to help us you'll see
the end existing end of the turning it
here currently it's Bo larded off to the
to the out to the green area but they've
drawn this red line figuratively through
here to give you an idea of the the
width it's about three point three
meters in width and 15 meters in depth
and inside it create an access that you
can see on the lower image there of the
yellow now the construction of it you'll
see from the report is it would remove
the soil to a depth of slightly
different to what's in the report but it
says about we've calculated about 300
millimeters about about a foot or so
hopefully this imager help us with that
and it's been overlaid with a concrete
crush mixed about six inches 200 mil or
so then above that some soil and sand
and on the top would be an echo system
and for members benefit it's like a
plastic grille yeah that members are
probably seen in public car parks which
the pockets are planted with soil and
grass seeds so the idea is it becomes a
hard enough surface that's durable for
the access but the grass in theory grows
through it better rather than being a
harsh surface material so this
interlocks on the surface for the
duration there we see in section you see
there's the the undisturbed soil the
base that would be put in then a layer
of soil and the system would sit on the
top with the grass growing out of it
it's not grass great but it's like an
alternative some members are familiar
with grass create as an option that's
concrete blocks with holes this is a
plastic pavia system which you'll see
that the soil in the grass root and grow
through it's also very porous it allows
the
surface to take the water to feed the
grass with it now you'll see that given
that it has that soft porous surface
that's grassed it has a better visual
appearance to the the street and the
area locally it's a more suitable more
friendly like softer surface so officers
don't feel that there's any visual
amenity consequence if I can get back to
the plan members will probably recall
that there are some preserved trees in
the grounds of the Raley lodge but the
nearest of them are about 20 meters or
so away from the proposed access so we
don't feel that these works will
interfere with the routing systems of
those preserved trees in any way now
given that there wouldn't be that harm
to any of the vegetation that's
preserved the softness of the of the
surface members will see that the
Highway Authority has no objections
subject to a couple of conditions which
I believe are reflected in the report
the recommendation is there for approval
subject to those conditions you'll see
at paragraph seven point one I can sir
Stanley as a visitor I lose the
opportunity to speak
can you just shoot your microphone play
says it's recorded properly sorry sorry
we was complete was worried about that
as the poster being taken away that's
already there would if there is no
obstacles to stop other vehicles parking
on the green it cannot just stop you
there just need to make it clear you're
saying at Raley town counts when you set
up with we've got the formal
representation from the Town Council
just need to appreciate that you're it's
you say me yeah yeah which I obviously
broke this up as well but what we was
looking at or what I was looking at at
the time when we looked at it was that
there are obstacles there at the moment
the bollards if you like whether they be
wood or whatever
would it not if they're going to come
away then it would allow parking to the
right-hand side where the trees or
whatever there is there be used so they
could run off and run onto that should
any visitors come into that closed and
was wondering if we if obstacles what
those bollards could be put along that
line that red line to stop that let's
that's all we've got so they get any
other members wishing to speak
councillor Newport and just one question
about whether there'd be any parking
restrictions in that turn in head
because it may be used for visitor
parking at the moment there's no parking
restriction at the moment no indication
of anything in the report counselor mr.
Hoyt
thank you the impalas are I assume a
relatively new addition because there
something on Google Maps when you look
at the street view I'm guessing that's
because there was a problem with people
going on to the grass previously is it
possible to add the condition that
counselors nanny mentions at mrs.
Frank's picture
chairman if I make a tape members point
and it would be something that you know
perhaps as planners we would normally
consider to that end in the run-up to
this meeting I found out that as part of
the license that's already been granted
the council's position was very clear to
the applicant that no boundary
demarcation was to be provided I'm not
sure as to the reasoning that the
applicant for this is already in of the
view that we as a council in another
place of it have said they don't want
any boundary demarcation I think the
applicant themselves was interested in
providing out sort of a ranch-style
fence at the side and I think bollards
had been suggested and it's my
understanding I may be incorrect for
members of a part of that process but
the the ambition of the council was to
keep hidden soar a wider space as
possible just with this surface over at
the suggestion of the bollards
rightfully preventing access because
access is still possible I think unbel
added off coffered Avenue the other end
but there was a an ambition I believe
not to provide the bollards as part of
this scheme cancelled rank of course
what
as you know chairman what somebody else
in the Council believes is relevant at
all to what this committee decides I can
understand that we counsel movement of
you launched our fence that would be too
intrusive but I would say I would
certainly support bollards wouldn't ones
from my side of things as that stands at
the moment as you see in the pit in the
picture you you have the open view of
the green space in I've got Rockford
Avenue
I think if you demarcate it with
bollards I think that might take
something away from the immunity if it
were a black top surface I think the the
argument for demarcation will be strong
but as the appearance of the surface as
illustrated through the the the
reinforcement system has been explained
it will the view that you see will
essentially remain as the view as you
see it there and as such I think I would
be inclined to leave the status quo
because it is something that can be
dealt with at a later stage because the
vehicles start to go on to our land it's
something that it is within our gift
albeit in another place to do something
about cancel cut mark thank you children
nothing could really what we're talking
about here is diminutive really acity
it's you know very small application
other than the bullets which I think are
releasing because I looked at so they
weren't there when I looked on Google
I've actually got here's not that you
know clearly that's been put there to
stop because I know that when we had a
site because it at this place must be
three years ago that there were vehicles
parked on it as I remember so that might
be why but because that was access to
the other Road to the house at the end
why on earth it was built that way I've
really no idea you know that how that
got through the relevant planning
situation at the time but just to say I
think I'm quite I sort of accede to your
view chairman in that what I don't want
to do is spoil the amenity of the green
that's there already and I think the
applicant is done their very best to
make sure that it actually looks as it
as almost as it looks now but without
the bullets okay so you know from that
point of view I think it's very good
thank you to everyone counsel after
yeah okay they're on like a second that
one that's the high all right yeah place
actually disagree totally in your
interpretation you're saying with
Worcester with the the surface looks
like grass we don't need to be my case I
think we need more - somebody's weather
say well they're parking over time I'm
not realizing but it is a grass surface
perhaps and it will only encourage
people other people people to move into
the glass so I don't anything too
intrusive but I think those those three
wouldn't bother it at the moment don't
affect the openness in any way and I
think something on that scale to
demarcate along that side will be vented
cancer sparing thank you Jim I think it
was caught between a rock and a hard
place here because three bollards on
that length because we just thought
between them it's as simple as that as
you said I mean it is it is our land
if we find that it is becoming an issue
that people are parking on it and they
haven't and as far as I'm aware at the
moment than parking on it then next
respectively we could put the bollards
in on on our land but I would think
putting three over the length of
obviously 15 meters something like that
because we just drive between the
bollards you you either need something
that they can't drive between um you
wouldn't need more than three and I
think it may be one of these situations
that we have to really extend as it is
another take the followed certainly to
left-hand bollards out if we find it
becomes an issue then we address it when
it becomes an issue but other what
you're going to end up I would suggest
we've probably 10 bones just to avoid
traffic driving between them Cass the
horn he wants to come back
yes Thank You chairman I think um if you
do look on the maps I think that's a
good we have Google Maps or not nowadays
another very Walt and I and again and if
you look to the left the picture is
missing out some bushes or trees
virtually just cut off from by that
venture nothing three three of those
posts would be expert to stop access
from there and I already do counsel to
cut mine Thank You chairman just to say
um I think that it may not be clear from
what we're looking at is that's a photo
that's there at the moment but you can
see that there is vegetation there that
stops people going at least half the way
a good compromise might just be a bit of
more planting the other side of that
vegetation just to stop people turning
on it what's what's wrong with that you
know just some bushes that keepo i think
we within the planning we just need to
look consider council of lacks a moment
on the principle of are we talking to
rather than the odd council black i
think just before you sum up I think
it's a relatively simple item so if you
you just want to finish off and then
we'll vote on your amendment
just go out the demarcation the word is
demarcation is to indicate that the
separation of the grass from that
surface and whilst I know we could talk
about more planting and doing it later
you know that would be an extra
executable Council to do so if
councillor competencies not a big thing
it is de minimis almost but I just think
three bothers with improving muscle okay
remembers on council of blacks amendment
for the provision of demarcation along
that line those favors members in favor
of adding the amendment for demarcation
please indicate those against Europe
your amendment is lost right members
will go to the main recommendation which
I think we fully explored now on six
point four that planning permission via
they approved with the conditions as
indicated in the report those members in
favor of the recommendation please
indicate those against that's I so
miscarried and that takes us through to
the end of the meeting thank you very
much